ونحييكم من جديد ايقافه رئيس الحكومه فتحي
بشاعه واحالته الى التحقيق زاد المشهد
السياسي المتوتره في ليبيا وجعله اكثر
ارباحا وبعد تنحيته وتعين بديل عنه لرئاسه
الحكومه المكلفه في ليبيا اوضح المتحدث
الرسمي باسم مجلس النواب لبيه عبد الله
ملاحق ان حكومه بشاغه التي تشكلت العام
الماضي بتكليف من مجلس النواب فشلت في
الوفاء بتعهدتها كما اشار الى ان بشاغا لم
ينفذوا عوده وفي مقدمتها العمل من داخل
العاصمه طرابلس واعتبر ان حكومه بشاقه
اخلقت او اخفقت على المستويين الخدمي
والسياسي كما قال مجلس النواب من جانبه
ناقش مساله تعثر الحكومه في اداء مهامها
والوفاء بتعهداتها قبل نيلها الثقه وعدم
تحقيقها لاهدافها والبرنامج الذي تقدمت به
امام البرلمان لكن المتحدث باسم مجلس اكد
عدم سحب الثقه من الحكومه والاكتفاء فقط
بايقاف بشاقه عن العمل وبتكليف وزير
الماليه اسامه حماد بمهامي رئاسه الحكومه
الى حين انتهاء التحقيق مع بشغه السبب
الرئيسي وراء ايقاف البشاعه لم يتم اعلانه
رسميا لكن احمد الروياتي مستشار رئيس
الحكومه الموقوف عن العمل اشار مسبقا الى
ان خلافات حول توزيع اموال الموازنه
العامه هي السبب وراء تفويض بشاعه نائبه
القيامه بمهامه كما اكد انه تعرض الى ضغوط
كبيره من تيارات سياسيه مختلفه حول تصريف
الموازنه العامه للدوله
قرر مجلس النواب
ايقاف السيد رئيس الحكومه سيد فتحي باشا
اغا واحالته للتحقيق
والتكليف السيد وزير الماليه الدكتور
اسامه حماد بمهام رئاسه الحكومه الى حين
انتهاء التحقيقات في مع السيد رئيس
الحكومه الامر متعلق بعدم الوفاء
بتعهداتها وتعهدات السيد رئيس الحكومه في
مقدمتها تعهداته بعمل الحكومه من داخل
العاصمه طرابلس ودخول العاصمه طرابلس وهذا
اول تعهد لم تفي به الحكومه او لم يتحقق
ايضا عدم تحقيق البرامج التي تعاهدت
الحكومه بها فبالتالي هذه هي
النقاط التي ادت الى ايقاف السيد رئيس
الحكومه
اسباب ايقاف بشغه البرلمان حكومته فشلت في
الوفاء بتعهداتها
واخفق على المستويين الخدمي والسياسي
حكومته لم تنفذ برنامجها الذي قدمته
للبرلمان واتخذ من سرت مقرا لحكومته لم
يتمكن من العمل من داخل العاصمه طرابلس
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا بنغازي فتحي
عبد الكريم المريمي المستشار الاعلامي
لرئاسه مجلس النواب الليبيه اهلا بك من
طرابلس سنوسي اسماعيل المتحدث السابق باسم
المجلس الاعلى للدوله الليبيه اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من طرابلس
معك
ما رايك فيما قاله البعض بخصوص عدم قدره
بشغه على الايثاء بتعهداته البعض شكك في
ما اتهم به بشغه وقيل بانه الموضوع يعود
الى خصومات ضيقه بينه وبين مجموعه من
النواب حضرتك هل ترى بانه كان يجب ايقاف
بشغه فعليا عن العمل وتحقيق معه طبعا
تحيه لكل ضيفك سيد مرعي ولكل الساده
المشاهدين
هو طبعا ما حصل من من تحركات في البرلمان
ومن ثم كانت هناك اتجاه الى سحب الثقه ثم
تغير
الاتجاه واصبح يعني ايقاف العمل وتحقيق
والى اخره انا في رايه انه يعني
انتهازيه مقيده الحقيقه ويبدو لي ايضا
انها من قبل بعض النواب طبعا ليس الكل
وايضا هي نوع من لنقل تحميل يعني الامور
ما لا
تحتونا عن الحكومه
هناك هناك
مشكله تقنيه على مستوى الصوت لا يصل
بطريقه واضحه ساترك بعض اللحظات لزملائنا
من حيث حضرتك وصفت هذا الاجراء بالاجراء
الانتهازي سانقل هذه النقطه لك سيد فتحي
الى حين العوده فيما بعد السيد السونسي في
طرابلس سيد فتحي هل ترى كذلك وتتفق مع
ضيفي بان هذا الاجراء اجراء انتهازي
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي الكريمه بسيدك
الضيف اسماعيل
وبالساده والسيدات مشاهدي قناتكم المؤقره
لا ليس هناك انتهاز ولا اي شيء في هذا
الامر الامر طبعا عادي ومن صلاحيه مجلس
النواب المسائله ومن صلاحيه مجلس النواب
الايقاف والعقاله هذين صلاحيات يملك
المجلس النواب في حاله استدعى الامر ذلك
نحن في كل الاحوال يعني فيما يخص
السيد رئيس الحكومه السيد فتحي باشا اغا
ليس مقالا وليس مبعدا وليس مستبعدا ولكن
موقوف عن العمل الى حين التحقيق معه
والتحقيق ليس بمعنى التحقيق بتاع المحاكم
ودواوين الاداريه
والديوان المحاسبه وغيرها ولكن تحقق من ما
هو
متهم به السيد رئيس
الوزراء فتحي باشا
عن نقطه قانونيه حضرتك تقول بانه لم تسحب
منه الثقه هو توقف يعني لفتره ايام عن
العمل تم ايقافه الى حين التحقيق معه ولكن
الا يستوجب ذلك ثلاث جلسات على مستوى
البرلمان ام ان الثلاث جلسات لسحب الثقه
وهذا ما لم يتم
[موسيقى]
لا لا هو طبعا الاجراء اللي تم داخل مجلس
النواب هو توجيه يعني عدد من
الاسئله
للسيد رئيس الوزراء كما قلت لك
استدعى الامر يعني لدى اعضاء مجلس النواب
بايقافه عن العمل وتشكيل لجنه له للتحقق
مما وجه اليه من اسئله واتهامات
عندنا نتائج التحقيق هناك شهاده مجلس
النواب خطوه اخرى اما باستمراريه رئيس
مجلس الوزراء في العمل او اقالته لكن في
كل الاحوال ما هو جاري الان ليس اقاله
وانما توقف عن العمل الى حين اجراء تحقق
معه في مجموعه الاسئله التي تواجه بها عدد
من اعضاء مجلس النواب يوم امس في جلسه
مجلس النواب ولكن سيد فتحي اليس من الغريب
ايقافه عن العمل والانتخابات على الابواب
يقول البعض بان هذا سيؤثر على الانتخابات
ان لم ينسف هذه الانتخابات
لا هو الانتخابات حسب الترتيب لها يعني لا
زال الامر يعني نحن نقول بنهايه العام
كذلك الانتخابات لها ترتيبات اخرى تختلف
يعني ما هو موجود الان في مسائله لهذه
الحكومه الموجوده الان يعني بالعكس هناك
لا ترتيبات واتصالات ما بين الاطراف
الليبيه حول تشكيل حكومه واحده على مستوى
ليبيا ولكن لم يعن الاوان لذلك الان نحن
بصدد الحكومه التي يعني
اختارها مجلس النواب وهي حكومه السيف فتح
باشعاغه عليها العديد من الملاحظات الان
سيجرى التحقيق معها على ضوء التحقيقات
سيتم اتخاذ خطوه احيانا رئيس الوزراء
وطبعا الاتهامات هي راهي عاديه الموضوع له
علاقه بالاموال له علاقه بتنفيذ المشاريع
من عدمها من صرف اموال على مناطق دون
مناطق غيرها يعني مجموعه اسئله عاديه جدا
يحق لمجلس النواب ان يسالها للسيد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء ولكن حضرتك توصفها سيجاوب عن
ذلك نعم اذا كان وجد خلل كبير في ذلك سيتم
ايقافه فيما بعد واتخاذ الاجراءات في حقه
وهذا مفهوم ولكن حضرتك تعتبر هذه المساله
عاديه الى حين ان يجهز ضيفي ساحاول ان
انقل لك وجهات النظر المختلفه كذلك
والمتباينه مع ما تطرحه في حين انه حضرتك
ترى بان هذه المسائله عاديه البعض يراها
مساءله تعجيزيه بمعنى انه يطلب مثلا من
فتح بشره الدخول الى طرابلس ويقال بانه هو
وعد بذلك الشيء ولم يحقق طيب كيف يدخل الى
طرابلس ونحن تابعنا بانه حينما حاول كانت
هناك اشتباكات وكان هناك تصعيد
سيد فتحي هل تسمعني
استمعت للسؤال
الاول حول دخول حول دخول العاصمه اما بعد
دخول العاصمه ماذا قلت بالضبط
لا خلينا مع دخول العاصمه دخول العاصمه
طبعا كان مقرر لهذه الحكومه ان تعمل من
العاصمه طرابلس لذلك حسب الاتفاق مع اعضاء
مجلس النواب علما بان فخامه رئيس مجلس
النواب المستشار عقيله صالح عيسى يرى بان
كل الاجهزه الليبيه تعمل من مدينه سرت على
اعتبار ان مدينه ماطرابلس ليست امنه
ودائما فيها مواجهات وفيها ميليشيات لم
يتم تفكيكها بعد وفيها قوات اجنبيه
ومرتزقه وغيره من هذه الامور التي يعرفها
الجميع والدليل كل بعد فتره تحدث مواجهات
وتحدث يعني مشاكل وقضايا كبيره بالسلاح
داخل العاصمه طرابلس ولكن راى البعض ان
لابد ولهذه الحكومه ان تعمل من طرابلس
حاول السيد فتحي باشا اغا ذلك ولكن
الميليشيات المسلحه رفضت يعني تواجد في
طرابلس ومارس عمله من سرد لا باس يعني
يعني في النهايه بالكل هو سؤال حيوجه له
عن عدم دخول طرابلس لان حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يجاوب بشكل رسمي لمجلس النواب لماذا لم
يدخل العاصمه طرابلس
على هذا السؤال له داخل داخل مجلس النواب
هل تعتقد سيد فتحي بان التحقيق سينتهي
بعودته على راس الحكومه
هذه حسب نتائج التحقق اذا كانت الاجابات
يعني مقنعه لاعضاء مجلس النواب سيبدا في
مباشره عمله واذا كانت غير مقنعه لمجلس
النواب ربما تتم اقالته الامر هذا ياتي ما
بعد التحقيق وحسب اجاباتها وحسب قناعه
مجلس النواب بهذه الاجابات عندما تعرض في
الجلسات القادمه ان شاء الله صار ضيفنا من
طرابلس معنا سنوسي اسماعيل تعود لنا من
جديد مع صوت واضح هذه المره سيد سنوسي كنا
نتحدث في الواقع مع الاستاذ فتحي وهو قال
بان هذه المساله هي المساءله عاديه في
الواقع هو لم تتم عمليه سحب الثقه منه
بالمعنى الايقاف الدائم وانما هو تحقيق
عاديه سيجيب على هذا هذه الاسئله وليست
هناك تجاوزات بمعنى ليس هناك استفزاز في
عمليه ايقاف وهل لك تعليق
هو طبعا السيد المرمى ربما يتحدث عن عن ما
يدور ظاهرين في مجلس النواب لكن انا احاول
ان احلل المشهد بصوره اوسع لان ليبيا
التوازنات فيها التوازنات هشه وبالتالي
يعني من الصعب الحقيقه فهم هذا الاجراء
على انه مجرد اجراء عادي برلمان يمارس
صلاحيته نحن نتحدث هنا عن وضع صعب جدا في
ليبيا وداخل ليبيا سلام هش واستقرار مشكوك
فيه يعني ان يستمر وهناك اقليم ملتهم
بالحقيقه كل مره
نتفاجا يعني
باحدى دول الجوار تحصل فيها مشاكل منذ
فتره قريبه والان السودان ولا ندري من هي
الدوله القادمه غدا لذلك اعتقد بان
المحافظه على الاستقرار الهش الموجود الان
وتطويره طبعا وربما يعني السير نحو
يعني تكون فيها نوع من من
المحافظه على التوازن وربما الدفع في
اتجاه ان
الدول الاقليميه المتعارضه او حتى الدول
الاخرى المتعارضه حول ليبيا انها تتوافق
على اساس ان يكون لدينا مصالح مشتركه معها
غير متعارضه وبالتالي هذا ربما
دوله مستقره وواحد فكره حضرتك ولكن حضرتك
وكانك تشكك في الاهداف التي اتت من وراء
ايقاف السيد باشاغه وهنا يطرح السؤال من
المستفيد من ايقافه
والله الحقيقه انا لا ارى ان هناك مستفيد
نظرا لان ايقاف السيد بشاقه ربما يثير
صراع الاجنحه في المنطقه الشرقيه وهذا
ربما يتسبب في مشاكل للمنطقه الشرقيه
وايضا يقطع ربما حلقه الوصل بين غرب وشرق
البلاد لان حكومه السيد باشاغه برغم انها
لم تتولى السلطه والى اخره لكنها على
الاقل جزء من مشروع ربما يتم تطويره لاحقا
بحكومه جديده ربما يكون هناك توافقات اخرى
ولكن هذا يعني لا يكون لا يكون على حساب
على حساب الاستقرار الهش الموجود لذلك
انا ماذا ادم اريد ان اؤكد له للسيد
المريم ولكل الساده المشاهدين ولكن هو هو
اننا نحاول ان نبحث عن فرصه
لتطوير الوضع السياسي في ليبيا بدون
بصراحه البحث عن مصالح شخصيه مصالح ذاتيه
لبعض النواب يريدون مثلا تسير الميزانيه
كما يشاؤون وهذه وممارسه ضغوطات كبيره على
السيد فتحي في هذا الاتجاه وايضا
التعيينات التي كانوا يريدونها لشركات
ربما تتسبب في انقسامات في الشركات العامه
المملوكه للدوله وطبعا
اسمح لي ساعود لك ولكن في نفس هذا الاطار
كذلك تحدث عن انتقادات طالت هذا القرار
اسمحوا لنا ان نذكر بهذا الانتقاد ونعود
لنكمل هذا النقاش
يستمر مجلس النواب في عبثه السياسي فبعد
قيامه بحجب الثقه عن حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
دون التشاور مع المجلس الاعلى للدوله وعدم
اعتماده لميزانيه عامه للدوله الامر الذي
جعل حكومه الوحده الوطنيه تصرف الاموال
وتستخدمها دون رقيب او حسيب وبعد قيامهم
ايضا بتكليف السيد فتحي باشاغ رئيسا
لحكومه جديده واعتماد حكومته بصوره غير
شفافه ها هو الان يصدر قرارا بايقافه
بطريقه اقل ما قد يقال عنها انها مريبه
ندعو مجلس النواب الى الالتفات لمصلحه
الدوله العليا بالاتفاق مع المجلس الاعلى
للدوله على خارطه طريق واضحه تؤدي الى
الانتخابات في ظل حكومه موحده صغيره لغرض
اجراء الانتخابات وانهاء المرحله
الانتقاليه والكف عن الاسهاب في اصدار
القوانين والتشريعات التي لا تتطلبها
المرحله الحاليه
اعود مجدد لك سيد
سنوسي سيد سنوسي اسمح لي ان اختم معك بهذه
التغريده لسيد خالد المشري هو يقول بانه
تم تكليف السيد بشاغه واعتماد حكومته
بصوره غير شفافه وحتى عمليه ايقافه
والتحقيق معه كذلك عليها نقاط استفهام
عديده هل يمكن لهذه التصريحات السياسيه ان
تنعكس ارضا فدخل ليبيا
هو برغم ان صفحه السيد خالد بشري حدثت هذه
التغريدات لكنها يعني اوصلت رساله بكل
تاكيد من مجلس الدوله الى مجلس النواب بان
مجلس النواب هذه التصرفات التي يقوم بها
والتي تشغل اساسا المجلسين عن
المجلسان عن المهمه الاساسيه المهمه
الاساسيه حاليا هي خلق اطار قانوني وربما
الذهاب الى خيار حكومه انتخابات سواء بدمج
الحكومتين او بالذهاب الى خيار حكومه
ثالثه مصغره هذا كلها خيارات موجوده لكن
ان تكون هناك قرارات بهذا الشكل تتسبب
ربما في مزيد من الشرق ومزيد من الاضعاف
لمجلس النواب بالمناسبه مجلس النواب الان
يعني بدلا من ان يحاول ان يتواصل مع مجلس
الدوله يمارس هذه هذه انا اسميتها
انتهازيه في بنغازي وهذه هذا الاستاساد
على حكومهم يعلمون انها حكومه يعني فيها
فيها نوع من الهشاشه وانها فقط تمثل حلقه
وصل بين الشرق والغرب ولكنهم حينما
يستاسدون عليه بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد بان
هذا اضعاف حتى لمجلس النواب ذاته لحساب
ربما يعني مصالح شخصيه ذاتيه
فتحة عبد الكريم المريم المستشار الاعلامي
لرئاسه مجلس النواب الليبي ومن طرابلس
سنوس اسماعيل المتحدث السابق باسم المجلس
الاعلى للدوله الليبيه شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات